bonjour Alain duamel merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous on ne vous présente
plus éditorialiste auteur de ce livre
qu'en revanche je vais présenter le
prince balafry Emmanuel Macron et les
Gaulois très réfractaires C aux éditions
de l'Observatoire vous êtes un fin
observateur de la vie politique depuis
de nombreuses années évidemment on a
envie d'avoir votre regard sur ce qu'il
s'est passé ces dernières heures et ce
nouveau gouvernement de Gabriel hatal
maintient des poids lourds de la droite
et la surprise Rachid adati est-ce que
vous le qualifiez de gouvernement de
droite ce gouvernement àal oui c'est un
gouvernement qui penche nettement à
droite ceux qui sont le plus à gauche
c'est Gabriel Atal lui-même et séjourné
au korsé mais enfin l'ensemble
l'ensemble du gouvernement oui penche à
droite plus qu'avant hier Gabriel Atal
s'en est défendu disant que c'est un
gouvernement équilibré il était l'invité
du 20ur de TF1 il y a lui il y a
Stéphane séjourné il y a Sylvie
rotaillot pour vous c'est non c'est un
gouvernement de droite oui oui sans
hésitation il suffit de voir sa
composition un peu dans le détail ceux
qui ont les principales responsabilités
sont des gens qui ont des convictions de
droite ça j'espère que c'est de la
droite
intelligente c'est pas incompatible
c'est quoi la droite intelligente bah
c'est la droite réaliste et pas
obscurantiste c'est c'est la droite
moderniste et pas régressive c'est qui
la droite régressive bah si on voit si
on voit la discussion sur la loi sur
l'immigration on voit très bien qu'
était régressif et qui ne l'était pas
est-ce que la composition de ce
gouvernement qui penche à droite c'est
aussi la fin du macronisme originel la
fin du en même temps alors je ne crois
pas plus exactement ça va dépendre de ce
qui se passera
euh
visiblement le mois de ce mois de
janvier mais ça je pensais avant je
l'avais dit avant d'ailleurs ce mois de
janvier est absolument essentiel pour la
fin de ce deè quinquena et en
particulier la semaine prochaine les
annonce que veut faire
Emmanuel Macron vont déterminer ce que
sera selon ses espérances bien entendu
ensuite la réalité sociale tranche mais
ce que sera
l'orientation de la fin du quinquena
c'est à ce moment-là qu'on verra on on
peut faire une politique équilibrée avec
des minist de droite c'est il peut y
avoir une politique du centre menée par
des ministres de droite ça existe ça
existe également dans l'autre sens
évidemment mais c'est là qu'on sera
vraiment donc pour vous c'est pas tant
dans la composition de ce gouvernement
que dans à la fois le discours de
politique générale de Gabriel et dans
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron qui va
falloir la su absolument et les disons
que les les principaux postes sont
occupés par des gens qui se Pench à
droite mais qui sont des gens de bonne
qualitéach surprise pour vous oui
complète euh ne serait-ce que parce que
j'avais en tête c'était pas très
original mais enfin c'était ça faisait
partie de l'pure qu'elle voulait avant
tout être la prochaine maire de Paris
bon donc je Nimagine incompatible pour
vous ça acte d'un accord déjà entre les
républicains et renaissance pour la
mairie de Parisi pour moi je suppose que
ça veut dire qu'il y a un accord pour la
mairie de Paris alors cela dit
le ceux qui
votent pour disons les roniste en
simplifiant à Paris sont plus à gauche
que la moyenne des électeurs macronistes
de France et donc comment est-ce qu'ils
vont
réagir à une éventuelle candidature de
rachidati pour la mairriie de Paris au
nom de renaissance et de dissidents de
LR ça n'est pas à quiis et et comment
vont réagir les LR on a vu que dans les
minutes qui ont suivi l'annonce de la
nomination de Rachid hadti Eric Sotil
président des républicains a acté son
exclusion du parti c'est un coup dur
voir le coup fatal pour les républicains
cette entrée de Rachid gouvernement al
fatal on verra ça au moment de des
élections européennes puis municipales
ce qui pour les républicains comme pour
les socialistes est absolument essentiel
parce que ce sont leurs derniers
bastions on verra
ça disons que en tout cas pour les
républicains c'était une très mauvaise
nouvelle et c'était la concrétisation
avec quelqu'un qui est très connu très
contesté y compris par moi mais très
connu bon et que le signal envoyé à leur
électorat est désastreux parce que ce
qui se passe c'est ce qu'ils essayent
d'éviter depuis presque 2 ans
c'est-à-dire un
rapprochement avec l'équipe d'émanuel
Macron mais est-ce que de facto ce
gouvernement il ne répond pas à la
sociologie de ce que sont devenus les
électeurs macronistes ça je je suis
d'accord avec vous euh ce gouvernement
est le reflet délibéré de l'évolution
politique de l'électorat français
l'électorat français est de plus en plus
à droite et ce gouvernement est de plus
en plus parallèle parmi les les figures
qui sont maintenues et qui est numéro 2
he du gouvernement il y a Bruno Lemer
dont vous dites dans votre livre qu'il
tient par-dessus tout à son autonomie et
considère Emmanuel Macron comme son seul
vrai interlocuteur est-ce que ça veut
dire que le plus grand défi de Gabriel
hatal ça va être d'affirmer son autorité
ah Gabriel Attal est très jeune très
doué mais effectivement un de ces
problèmes va être vis-à-vis de ceux qui
sont si je dire les ducs et pères au
sein de ce gouvernement et le premier
d'entre eux euh c'est effectivement
certainement Bruno leemire euh ils n'ont
pas d'antagonisme
euh en matière économique en matière
politique Brau leemire a certainement
des aspirations il aurait certainement
voulu être Premier ministre il a
peut-être envie d'être candidat à
l'élection présidentielle mais c'est
effectivement un des défis de Gabriel
Atal c'est d'imposer son autorité
imposer son autorité ça veut pas dire en
permanence qu'il va appeler Bruno Le
Maire pour lui dire ce qu'il faut faire
bien entendu Bruno Le Maire il aura il
aura son autonomie mais ça veut dire que
c'est lui le patron Gabriel Atal don
dont vous dites dans votre livre qu'il
est incontestablement le plus brillant
il aura l'occasion de prouver ce qu'il
vaut il a autant d'ambition que tuas
cité déjà des enennemis déjà des rivaux
c'est un homme pressé et un politique né
sa nomination ça a pas été une sur ise
pour vous non j'ai trouvé que c'était à
Paris un Paris audacieux bien sûr cont
tenu de son âge mais je pense que c'est
en politique le plus doué de des
macronistes et qu'il ait des des
perspectives ça me paraît absolument
évident ce qui manque beaucoup chez
macronist c'est pas du tout des gens
compétents ils ont des pelletés entières
de gens compétents ce qui leur manque
c'est des politique mais est est-ce que
justement la nomination de gabrielal et
ce gouvernement acte la fin de la
société civile et le retour d'un
gouvernement politique pour vous en tout
cas euh c'est un politique qui est nommé
à la tête du gouvernement clairement bon
il est le premier des premier ministres
de d'Emmanuel Macron depuis 2017 à ne
pas être un très haut fonctionnaire
passé à la politique c'est quelqu'un qui
a fait la politique toute sa vie euh à
25 ans il avait déjà il était conseiller
municipal donc et et il n'a fait que ça
il s'est préparé com complêtement il na
fait que ça bon il est très doué euh on
va voir comment il se débrouille euh à
l'Assemblée et cetera j'ai pas beaucoup
de d'inquiétude pour lui il serura à
faire il est très bon dans les questions
d'actualité il serura répondre et cetera
s'il y a des polémiques il sera à son
aise tout ça très bien sur les dossiers
techniques on va voir comment ça se
passera on va on va revenir à
l'Assemblée mais un mot est-ce que le
fait qu'il soit très politique il va
redonner un sens à la fonction de
Premier ministre est-ce que ce sens il a
été perdu ces dernières années pour vous
bah ça dépend avec qui Édouard
Philippe il avait quand même conquis une
part non négligeable du pouvoir on se
rappelle par exemple pendant le covid il
existait il existait il y avait un
partage des rôles avec Emmanuel
Macron avec Elisabeth borne c'était
différent et l'autonomie du Premier
ministre c'était assez largement
affaé je pense que c'est l'intérêt et je
crois que c'est l'intention d'Emmanuel
Macron de permettre à à Gabriel Atal non
seulement de d'exister par lui-même mais
d'avoir un un poids ses inflexions son
ton
et d'incarner quelque chose de différent
évidemment pas d'antagoniste mais de
différent il va pouvoir le faire parce
que Gabriel Atal il s'est empressé de
dire des sa passation de pouvoir qu'il
devait tout à Emmanuel Macron difficile
dans ces caslà d'illeurs j'ai trouvé
qu'il le disait un peu trop euh qu'il le
disent ça allit de
soi être nommé être nommé à à 34 ans
Premier ministre c'est normal qu'on
remercie celui qui vous y nomme mais
j'ai trouvé dans dans ça m'a étonné
d'ailleurs que il y revenait au moins
trois fois dans son échange avec
ellisabeth borne c'était au moins une
fois de trop mais est-ce qu'il va
réussir à s'émanciper du
coup je crois que euh
Emmanuel Macron a bien
compris qu'il fallait un premier
ministre existant par lui-même et que
c'était son intérêt à lui que lui
s'occupe des grands dossiers évidemment
toute façon les grands dossiers c'est ça
sera forcément le président de la
République et à forceorie quand il
s'appelle les monel Macron on le sait
bien
euh son intérêt qui est un Premier
ministre qui existe vraiment c'est ENF
je dirait que ça va même être essentiel
là on va avoir une phase qui est quand
même une phase très compliquée quand
euh quand Gabriel Atal arrive on est
quand même en pleine crise
internationale on est en grande
difficulté économique on a devant nous
des échéances importantes à commencé par
les Jeux Olympiques et
cetera il faut quelqu'un qui existe
vraiment et et qui allège un peu la
tâche du président de la République mais
mais c'est la première fois que
qu'émanuel Macron nomme quelqu'un qui
est plus populaire que lui il est très
populaire Gabriel Atal Édouard Philippe
Jean Cass
quand ils sont arrivés à matinon c'était
des quasi inconnu est-ce que c'est
forcément un bon coup politique ou
est-ce qu'au contraire ça risque de lui
revenir en boomerang parce que gabrial
va l'éclipser non je crois pas du tout
que Gabriel hatal l'éclipsera parce que
le le patron c'est le président
euh c'est vrai que les présidents en
général et Emmanuel Macron comme les
autres n'aiment pas beaucoup qu'on soit
plus populaire queeux mais la différence
c'est que Emmanuel Macron il n'est pas
candidat à la prochaine présidentielle
donc ça dédramatise cette question de
savoir qui est le plus populaire si il
envisagé d'être candidat la Constitution
l'interdit évidemment ça aurait été une
autre affaire là je crois pas que ça
soit essentiel est-ce que on va parler
de de la de l'Assemblée nationale
Gabriel Attal ne dispose pas d'une
majorité relative est-ce que ça réussite
à matigon dépend de sa capacité à
traiter avec les oppositions et de quel
premier ministre il peut s'inspirer pour
ça alors qu'il est besoin de traiter
avec les oppositions à l'Assemblée et au
Sénat c'est essentiel et là il y a ceux
qui apprèsent ou qui savent et puis ceux
qui ne savent pas parmi les premier
ministres on voit bien que c'est
extrêmement différent en particulier
d'un président de la République à un
autre on voit des premier ministres
habiles et d'autres qui le sont moins
dans ce domaine lui il connaît bien
quand même les assemblées
euh il essaiera de
et même ses adversaires y compris des
gens des insoumis et et du rassemblement
national
euh au moment où il a été nommé ont tous
reconnu que il avait un contact non
seulement courtois mais mais honnête et
sympathique avec ses interlocuteurs
d'opposition bah il a tout intérêt à
rester sur cette ligne qui est le modèle
en la matière si vous pensez à un
premier ministre
euh s'y prenant très bien bah il y a eu
Michel Rocard qui il faut dire avait un
un conseiller parlementaire qui
s'appelait guarcasson qui était un
véritable génie dans ce domaine et qui
n'a jamais été égalé et de loin et qui a
lui seul pesé une vingtaine de voix à
l'assemblée mais oui là là il y a eu une
véritable ouverture et d'ailleurs ce qui
est intéressant c'est que quand Michel
Rocard que je connaissais bien était
premier ministre il y avait vraiment des
lois qui passaient avec la droite ou le
centre plutôt d'ailleurs et des lois qui
passaient avec la gauche et que c'était
bien géré et et que ça a permis
d'avancer il y a eu des choses
importantes qui ont été faites à ce
moment-là est-ce qu'il est en capacité
d'élargir la majorité Gabriel pour vous
euh à l'Assemblée ou au Sénat sûrement
pas euh les les les républicains vont
être plus crispés que jamais évidemment
parce que là ils sont sur la défensive
parce qu' se produit avec l'entrée de
Rachid hadti si elle est gérée parce que
gérer Gabriel hatal pour Emmanuel Macron
je pense que c'est presque facile gérer
Rachid adati bon courage il a pris un
risque ah oui bah c'est évident euh il a
réussi à coup mais il a pris un risque
est-ce qu'il va aussi peut-être avoir du
mal avec sa propre majorité est-ce que
la composition de ce gouvernement peut
créer des difficulté notamment avec
François baayerou qui demandait un
gouvernement au centre et qui se
retrouve avec un gouvernement très à
droite oui mais François baayerou c'est
le véritablement l'empêcheur de danser
en rond dans cette majorité et il a
l'influence parce que son groupe
parlementaire qui est
important le suit très largement il
n'est pas content de ce de cet équilibre
à droite
euh mais enfin il s'est quand même
opposé à plusieurs candidatures c'était
déjà vrai pour ellisabeth borne est il a
joué un rôle essentiel pour que ça ne
soit pas Catherine fautrin qui
maintenant fait son entrée au
gouvernement et ça a été vrai cette
fois-ci puisque en fait il ne voulait
pas de de Gabriel Atal et il préféré de
Normandie qui d'ailleurs est quelqu'un
de très bien par ailleurs euh simplement
euh François baayerou moi je connais par
cœur depuis des décennies et des
décennies c'est un homme politique très
doué c'est quelqu'un de très cultivé qui
est qui a un sens politique aigu mais
c'est pas à lui de former le
gouvernement et c'est pas à lui de
choisir le Premier ministre
ça sur la 5e République qu'Emmanuel
Macron l'écoute moins pour vous non il
l'écoute pas moins parce queil l'entend
très fort mais cette fois-ci il a passé
outre pour au moment de la nomination
d'Élisabeth borne il a accepté il a
accepté de renoncer à celui qui voulait
nommer et cette fois-ci il a nommé celui
qui voulait ce que je trouve quand même
plus sain il a des capacités de nuisance
François Baayou vous le disiez il a une
cquantaine de députés ou est-ce qu'il va
rentrer dans le rang pour vous oh non je
crois pas qu'il rentre jamais dans le
rang son son principe d'autonomie est
absolu donc il y a un risque donc a un
risque bien sûr et avec Édouard Philippe
Édouard Philippe peut d'abord il peut
difficilement être mécontent du fait que
le gouvernement penche vers la droite
bon c'est là où il est donc il y a pas
de raison et ensuite et il a de ministre
Catherine vauttin Christophe voilà et et
en
plus je crois qu'il n'a pas intérêt à ce
que les ses relations
avec le président de la République
s'éigrisse parce que lui il veut quasi
officiellement être candidat euh il ne
sera pas candidat
grâce à Emmanuel Macron mais il ne peut
pas être candidat contre Emmanuel Macron
et la nomination de gabrielal de ce
point de vue là c'est une bonne ou une
mauvaise nouvelle pour Édouard Philippe
est-ce que d'avoir quelqu'un de très
populaire qui va rentrer dans la
lessiveuse de matigon ça peut l'arranger
ça n'est pas une très bonne ça n'est pas
une très bonne nouvelle c'est pas une
très bonne nouvelle parce que ça met en
lumière quelqu'un qui peut lui faire de
l'ombre bah par principe et quelqu'un et
quelqu'un qui en a
l'aptitude un dernier mot sur cette
majorité et sur le Parlement est-ce que
pour vous Gabriel doit demander un vote
de confiance après son discours de
politique générale est-ce que ça
illustrerait le courage et l'audace dont
il fait ses maîtres mot non parce que si
s'il demande un vote il le perdra
évidemmentah bien sûr ni à gauche ni
chez les républicains ni à for au
rassemblement national personne ne
voterait la confiance comm il y a une
majorité relative ça veut dire qu'il a
une minorité
absolue en cas de vote de confiance
alors ça voudrait dire qu'il renonce à
sa tâche à peine arrivé c'est ça n'a pas
de sens on va parler de Gabriel hatal et
de sa jeunesse puisque évidemment
Gabriel hatal est le plus jeune premier
ministre de l'histoire avant lui c'était
Laurent fabus il était l'invité de
Guillaume Durand sur notre antenne dans
l'émission Au Bonheur des livres on va
écouter ce que dit Laurent fabus on m'a
très gentiment mis sur mon bureau deux
titres du journal Libération euh l'un
que j'ai vu récemment le le libération
titre je crois
euh monsieur Macron se nomme à Matignon
et ils ont fait exactement le titre le
même titre lorsque moi j'étais nommé en
disant mitéron se nomme à matigon donc
bon très bien le seul le seul
commentaire que que je puis faire euh
c'est que il paraît que jusqu'à la
nomination de Monsieur hatal j'étais
recordman de la
jeunesse j'aime beaucoup le sport je
dirais et cette phrase certainement sera
méditée les records sont faits pour être
voilà très bien et je n'irai pas dans
d'autres commentaires voilà la réaction
de Laurent fabus on peut faire un
parallèle entre la nomination de Laurent
fabus et celle de Gabrielle Atal pour
vous alin duamel oui
euh parce que dans les deux cas ça a été
une surprise dans les deux cas la
surprise était au bénéfice de quelqu'un
de jeune et passant pour très dououé
alors Laurent fabus avait un spectre
plus large que celui de Gabriel Atal
aujourd'hui parce que c'était à la fois
un politique et un vrai politique et en
même temps c'était quelqu'un qui avait
la formation d' très haut fonctionnaire
qui avait déjà été ministre du Budget et
Dieu sait qu'il avait en kikiné Jacques
De Lor qui était lui le ministre de
l'économie et des finances à ce
moment-là il avait une surface politique
plus importante que Gabriel Atal
aujourd'hui ça ne s'était pas passé
idéalement parce que à l'émission que
que je coanimé à cette époque qui était
l'heure de vérité je avais posé la
question maintenant que maintenant que
vous êtes premier Premier ministre
est-ce que vous allez simplement êre vos
pas dans les pas de François mitteran et
il m'avait fait cette réponse qui est
bien connue lui c'est lui moi c'est moi
moyen en quoi François miteran le
lendemain matin m'avait appelé à 1 heure
étrangement dérangeante
euh et voulant absolument tout savoir
des conditions dans lesquelles il avait
répondu ce que j'avais compris de ses
intentions et en fait François mitteran
le lendemain matin fut
culminer donc là ça se passera mieux
selon vous entre entre Macron et Atal je
pense que ça se passera beaucoup mieux
euh ne serait-ce que déjà parce que il y
a pas de la la différence d'âge n'est
pas de même nature du tout et surtout la
différence de tempérament ne se compare
absolument pas on voit dans ce
gouvernement alors il y a Gabriel àal
mais pas que y a beaucoup de ministres
qui ont été nommés hier et qui ont moins
de 40 ans est-ce que c'est le signe que
la politique n'est pas morte et qu'elle
attire toujours alors je trouve que le
rajonnissement euh
en soi c'est quelque chose je suis
peut-être mal placé pour dire ça ou
peut-être honnête je pense que c'est une
nécessité et moi qui suis très européen
comme beaucoup de gens de ma génération
et comme moins de gens maintenant je
suis très content par exemple que pour
les élections européennes il y a autant
de gens jeunes pour diriger des listes
parce que c'est le cas de la liste du
Parti communiste c'est le cas de la
liste des écologistes ça sera le cas de
la liste des macronistes c'est le cas de
la liste évidemment de du rassemble
national ça je trouve probablement des
républiains François Xavier béami à 38
oui un peu moins jeune quand même mais
enfin il est encore très jeune c'est je
trouve que tout ça est tout ça est
positif tout ça est c'est souhaitable et
puis en politique c'est c'est comme
partout il faut qu'il y ait des
renouvellements est-ce que ça peut
amoindrir la la lourde fatigue
démocratique dont vous parlez dans votre
livre pour vous bah en tout cas ça ne
peut faire que du bien dans quelle
proportion je pense que la fatigue
démocratique que on on en sortira déjà
ce que je veux dire est un peu prosaïque
mais on en sortira déjà quand les gens
retrouveront plus d'espérance et auront
moins d'anxiété c'est-à-dire quand les
conditions de vie se seront amélioré
quand on sera sorti on peut espérer que
cette année on va progressivement sortir
de la crise économique je dis bien
progressivement et on verra comment les
choses tournent en Ukraine mais on est
dans une période extrêmement anxiogène
les gens ont besoin d'espérance et je
pense que pour revit is la démocratie la
première chose c'est c'est de c'est de
ressusciter l'espérance et l'espérance
ça ne se décrète pas ça peut s'incarner
ça peut se faciliter mais les gens
jugent d'abord leur environnement et
leurs conditions de vie vous parliez des
des européennes est-ce que la nomination
de Gabriel hatal ça donne un enjeu
national à ces élections européennes
est-ce que c'est la preuve qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne veut pas les enjamber
Emmanuel Macron ne peut pas enjamber ces
ces élections là ce qui l'identifie le
plus en tout cas pour le grand public
c'est son son choix de l'Europe et c'est
ce qu'il réussit le mieux en matière
internationale c'est son rôle en Europe
bien plus que en Afrique au Moyen-Orient
en Europe oui il a un rôle important et
il a un rôle
positif à partir de ce moment-là il faut
pas que les élections européenne soit
une déculotée pour son parti donc il
faut le maximum ser le cas ou est-ce que
Gabri car est-ce que c'est la meilleure
arme anti Bardella Gabriel àal bah c'est
alors il y aura lui il y aura sans doute
aussi sesjourné il y aura d'autres euh
en tout cas l'espérance c'est
effectivement de créer une dynamique et
donc de réduire l'é et qui pour conduire
la liste puisque Stéphane séjourn a été
nommé au cadora est-ce qu'il faut un
politique comme Olivier verrand par
exemple qui a été débarqué du
gouvernement je je dirais que c'est
assez secondaire parce que la la la
campagne elle sera menée d'abord par
Emmanuel Macron et par Gabriel Atal et
aussi par ses journées et quelques
autres mais ça sera l'engagement
d'Emmanuel Macron et et on verra si les
conditions seront positives en Europe
parce que ça n'est pas évident puisque
comme vous le savez on va entrer dans
une présidence
hongroise ce qui nous promet quelques
difficultés un dernier mot alin duamel
est-ce qu'en n gabrielal Emmanuel Macron
a désigné son successeur est-ce qu'il a
vraiment envie que le macronisme perdure
après lui selon vous alors je suis sûr
qu'il a envie le macronisme perdure euh
j'espère pour Gabriel hatal qu'il ne le
présentera pas comme son successeur
parce que le rôle de dauphin après
venant après deux mandats présidentiels
serait plutôt un handicap qu'un avantage
merci Alain duamel merci beaucoup pour
votre regard sur ce nouveau gouvernement
de Gabriel hatal et sur ce qui se passe
dans la vie politique actuelle je
rappelle votre livre le prince balafré
Emmanuel Macron et les Gaulois très
réfractaires c'est aux édition de
l'Observatoire merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité on passe au club des
territoires